he's been called the oracle of omaha
the sage of nebraska and from a young
age
he knew he would be rich i could figure
out when i was 10.
if i had a fairly long life i was going
to end up with a lot of money
and behind his folksy demeanor there's
one of america's shrewdest
and toughest businessmen you don't make
40 billion dollars by being mr rogers or
by being one of the muppets
warren takes no prisoners when it comes
to a negotiation he uses every bit of
leverage that he can
[Music]
for most of his life warren buffett has
avoided the wall street ways of risky
speculation
living and working in omaha where he was
born in 1930
and where his obsession with all things
financial began
i knew i was going to be interested in
stocks the rest of my life but probably
at the time i was
you know eight or nine i used to keep
charts on all kinds of stocks when i was
uh that age my aunt gave me a
a world woman act so i'm i memorized the
population of all
cities of any real size but i just like
numbers
it was not limited to business numbers
at all
buffett's ability to remember all those
numbers would be the bedrock of his
later success
my grandfather had a grocery store and i
used to buy
coca-cola from him in six packs for a
quarter and sell them for a nickel each
i sold the saturday evening post
door-to-door i sold ladies home journal
i had all kinds of little ventures not
not all hugely successful i might add i
like doing business early on
at 16 buffett enrolled at the wharton
school of the university of pennsylvania
where he roomed with charles peterson
every day after class i'd spend so many
hours
studying war on the contrary uh picked
up the
books that are applicable to him and uh
sat there and flipped through him page
by page
uh and he might be through two or three
courses in a couple weeks
he had a photographic mind
i did not buffett also developed
an early love of politics i was
president of the young republicans club
at the university of pennsylvania and
then
i even ran for delegate to the national
convention one time as a republican
after breezing through college buffett
got a graduate degree from columbia
business school
he then headed back to omaha to start
his own business
he said i'm going to form a partnership
and
he said would you want in i said sure i
do there was only
seven or eight people in that original
partnership
convincing people beyond the first seven
investors
got rockier my sales pitch wasn't very
effective i was i was 20 years old
i looked like i was about 16 and i
probably behaved like i was about 12.
so i would go around and call on people
they were always nice to me
but i would see a mr smith and and i
would go through
all these facts and figures about why
you should buy some stock
and when i got all through in my head i
would count to three i would go one
two three and then mr smith would say
what does your dad think and i would
always want to hit him but
it was frustrating buffett knew that he
had to be a better salesman
so he turned to popular self-help guru
dale carnegie
well i i had to be able to communicate
with people better and i mean in groups
particularly
i just knew that i couldn't go through
life terrified of public speaking and
i'd heard about the dale carnegie course
i mean i proposed to my wife during
during the dale carnegie course i mean i
got my money's worth
right off right during the course
buffett was finally ready to put his
career
in gear he was picking stocks that
others were ignoring
and his stocks kept going up little by
little
words spread around omaha that the kid
knew what he was doing
in the first five years that buffett was
in business the dow rose by
74 percent while buffett's investments
had gone up
250 percent in 1961
at the age of 30 he reached millionaire
status
but you couldn't tell that from the way
the family lived their home
which buffett still lives in was bought
over 50 years ago
for 32 thousand dollars his children all
went to public schools
susie buffett is the eldest of three
buffett children
we grew up in a way that uh i think is
probably different than most kids if
you've got a dad who has what my dad
has i mean we didn't get cars when we
turned 16.
we didn't we didn't live any differently
really than most of the other kids we
knew
the biggest change in the buff of
household was that warren was moving
away from the staunch republicanism
of his father civil rights had the
biggest effect on changing my
my views on politics neither party
necessarily covered themselves with
gloriana but it was clear to me that
a basic change a really basic change in
civil rights was called for and the
democrats seem to be
much more attuned to that than
republicans in his 30s
warren buffett wanted to find companies
that he could buy a controlling interest
in
and he found one a hundred miles away in
beatrice nebraska
dempstermill was a company that was
really not doing very well
it was in the windmill business of the
windmills now come back but
it was not a good business to be in 50
years ago but the stock was selling very
cheap so i started i started buying
stock in that
former wall street analyst alice
schroeder is the author of the snowball
buffett's authorized life story it was a
business
that had built up a lot of inventory
that it didn't need
and it had a labor force that was too
big so it was a company that just needed
to be downsized
and of course the town that it was in
was very small and it was the main
employer
a hundred people lost their jobs and
buffett
took the heat what it taught warren
buffett was that he did not want to get
involved anymore
in businesses that had labor problems
where he would have to fire people
where he would have to get involved
personally in the management he wanted
somebody else to do that
buffett's next big investment also
looked like a potential failure
it was a textile mill called berkshire
hathaway
whose stock was selling for seven
dollars and fifty cents a share
we bought a textile company that was
destined eventually to go out of
business just
like every other new england textile
company did it was a mistake
glenn tung is a managing partner for t2
partners
berkshire hathaway was not a good
business they didn't have a competitive
advantage that allowed them to earn
a sufficient return on the capital
invested in the business so while they
were profitable to some extent
that profitability was inexorably being
squeezed
when the cash was extracted out of
berkshire hathaway it was reinvested
first major reinvestment that was
enormously profitable was the insurance
business and that
drove everything that berkshire hathaway
did from then on
andrew fry is a reporter for bloomberg
news
so he moved the company basically from
textiles to insurance
and part of the reason was because the
industry itself generated profits but
also because
through the premiums that they gathered
up from their policy holders buffett was
able to take that
and make his stock investments it's
called the float
money comes in interest free from
insurance premiums
which then gets invested in other
businesses
buffett also found a professional
partner who was as market savvy as he
was
charlie munger who was working as a
lawyer when the two first met
when i met warren he immediately started
telling me how much better his way of
making a living was than mine and that i
was too smart to
stay in such a silly businesses law
practice when i could go into
his business of running an investment
partnership and it took me about two or
three years
to realize he was right
in the late 1960s wall street was in the
midst of an unprecedented boom
stock prices were soaring as everyone
rushed into the stock market
but for buffett it was time to get out
i was running a little over a hundred
million dollars
and had a lot of happy partners and i
wrote him a letter and i said you know i
don't know how to play in this game
anymore the
valuations have gotten to where i can't
find things
i terminated my partnership in 1969.
it seems counter-intuitive but warren
has always quoted
gus levy who said be greedy when others
are fearful
be fearful when others are greedy and
warren knew
that the party would come to an end and
at some point the bubble would burst
buffett was 40 years old and was worth
more than 25 million dollars
but he was restless and in 1973
made a fateful decision to buy into a
california bank
called wesco the problem was
wesco was in the middle of a merger deal
with another company
and the next thing you know the company
that was going to buy westco
complained to the securities and
exchange commission that warren was
trying to bust up their merger
which would have been illegal and so an
investigation launched
the sec went through every nook and
cranny of buffett's businesses
and what they saw alarmed them buffett
and mongers investments were a complex
spiderweb
of ownerships and cross ownerships
we had drifted in since we had several
companies so the whole thing looked like
so much spaghetti
that had been done for some evil master
purpose
we didn't feel we'd done anything
improper but there were a lot of rules
and
and the question was whether we violated
any
stanley sporkin was director of
enforcement at the sec
anytime you find that things are so
wired
that they take a long time to be able to
understand them
raises a suspicion that maybe somebody
is doing that
to get away with something what also
raised investigators suspicions
was that monger and buffett were
offering west coast shareholders
a higher price for their stock than they
could get on the open market
so we just kept buying until our
allotment ran out at two or three points
higher than
we had to well that was a very eccentric
thing to do but we thought it was the
right way to behave
and the sec went berserk trying to head
off disaster
buffett's lawyer made an unorthodox
appeal to stanley sporkin
and saying look as stan even though
this doesn't look good from your
standpoint i want you to take into
account the character of the individual
my view meaning rickerson's review he
probably is going to be the number one
person in the financial services
industry
of all time the appeal worked buffett's
company
was fined just over a hundred thousand
dollars but no charges were filed
against buffett
in 1973 berkshire hathaway stock price
hit a new high of ninety three dollars
its profits driven mostly by their
insurance businesses
buffett also owned stakes in banks
clothing makers
and candy factories but there was one
business
he was passionate about owning i love
newspapers i mean i started reading
newspapers
you know my dad would bring him home one
day i don't know whether i was six or
seven or
eight and it was the first thing i'd
grab my sisters would grab them too we
all like to read it
his first newspaper purchase was an
omaha weekly called
the sun the paper won a pulitzer prize
a rare honor for a small publication
he then started acquiring stock in the
washington post company
the paper was struggling financially
after the watergate scandal
1973 the stock had gone down a lot
partly in response to the fact that the
nixon administration has sort of
declared war on the washington post
[Applause]
the interesting thing is is when we were
buying that stack of twenty dollars a
share
if you'd asked the people who were
selling it to us how much the company
was actually worth the businesses they
would have said a hundred dollars a
share
but they sold it anyway i salute the
nixon administration forever
for stirring up the dust at that time
buffett's rule had always been to keep
his distance from his company's managers
and executives
but that was not the case at the
washington post
where publisher catherine graham became
his social partner
and confidante she was in a business
that fascinated me
so she would invite me to these various
washington parties which were
interesting i mean i
i saw parts of the world that i wouldn't
have seen otherwise
if we hadn't become friends
but as buffett's social circle widened
his wife susie was feeling increasingly
isolated back home
and made a bold decision she was not
divorcing warren
but she left omaha for san francisco to
pursue a new life
i get why she moved my dad was getting
more famous
and my mother was so not the mrs warren
buffett type
their relationship never changed at all
they were
completely in love with each other they
talked
five six seven eight times a day they
traveled together
um she just couldn't live here to make
sure that warren was taken care of in
her absence
susie turned to her friend astrid menks
within a few
months ostrid moved in it's very
unorthodox
a lot of people i'm sure talked about it
and
had all kinds of lovely things to say
about how weird it was but i also think
you know what
it's nobody's business what goes on in
somebody else's relationship
it worked for the three of them it
worked buffett made history
when he helped finance capital city's
takeover of the american broadcasting
company
the biggest media deal to date but his
golden touch wouldn't be enough
when buffett invested 700 million
dollars in solomon brothers
at the time the nation's largest
investment house
a few years after buffett's initial
investment
solomon got into big trouble it turned
sour when i got a call in august of
i guess 1991 they sort of hinted to me
about the problems that were coming
a trader named mosher had done some very
bad things in the government us
government bond market
those bad things included illegal moves
by that solomon trader to corner the
bond market
by using unauthorized accounts to
increase solomon's share
and force out their competitors derek
mourne was a vice chairman at solomon
brothers
though he had no involvement in the
scandal he was appalled at what was
happening
to me it was clear that we've broken the
law we've interfered with the workings
of a
critical market and that the treasury in
the fed would be
less than amused as ceo of solomon
brothers
john goodfriend was taking the blame for
the mess
i remember it vividly when you make the
front page in the right hand column of
new york times in the picture
but you're a fool which i probably was
my
distribute became national should have
been
one of the worst days of my life and
probably was
i told tom strauss
and john merriweather that we had to go
talk on wall street that solomon's top
officials were offering to resign
to prevent the firm's possible debarment
as a primary dealer in
treasury securities good friend made one
last desperate attempt to salvage the
company
with a phone call to omaha nebraska
asking buffett
to be the ceo and i wasn't
involved in the things so that i was not
tainted the hope was that i would be
credible
with all the people that were mad at us
there were a lot of them the crisis
deepened
when treasury secretary nicholas brady
ruled that solomon
was out of the bond business it was
announced that about
10 in the morning on a sunday the u.s
treasury had
knocked us off the list of really
acceptable people
primary dealers that would have been a
death blow to the company so i had to
get that
changed by the time tokyo opened
that would have been a national calamity
and
it looked for a long time as though the
government was just going to say the
hell with you solomon
warren buffett spent the entire day in
frantic phone calls to washington
trying to get the feds to back off i was
scared stiff
and it probably came through in my voice
there were a lot of people that wanted
us to go out of business over that
weekend and i didn't know what was going
to happen
at the 11th hour secretary brady gave
solomon
another chance to seal the deal buffett
had to personally take charge of
cleaning up the mess at solomon
it was miserable i was there nine months
and four days and it's not an accident
that i can tell you
20 years later exactly how long it was
there but
but it was important that it get done i
wouldn't wish it on anybody and i
wouldn't
wish what happened to the firm you know
on anybody but in a sense i learned a
lot
buffett emerged the hero warren buffett
meeting with the financial community
signing autographs they love him the man
with the squeaky clean image who's
trying to clean up the mess at
solomon brothers in 1993
berkshire hathaway stock hit seventeen
thousand dollars a share
and buffett was world famous but no
amount of global traveling could change
some
of buffett's ingrained habits let's talk
about warren's diet
here are the vegetables he'll eat corn
on the cob
french fries hash browns and the fruit
would be uh banana cream pie
strawberry shortcake i think that's the
end of the fruit he also drinks you know
several cherry cokes a day
i've never in my life and i'm not
kidding seen the man drink
a sip of water ever
the 1990s and 2000s would be the era of
berkshire hathaway's greatest
expansion brought into the corporate
fold was the nation's biggest furniture
store
a leading mobile home manufacturer fruit
of the loom underwear
benjamin moore paints dairy queen geico
insurance
over 70 companies in all with a combined
250 000 employees some investments
flew in the face of conventional wisdom
he bought his hometown newspaper
the omaha world herald and he bought the
burlington northern railroad
that is the thing that warren buffett
has done over and over as he invests in
something
and then everybody looks at it and says
i saw it there
why didn't i recognize these things all
along
in omaha berkshire hathaway's annual
meeting
has become a place of pilgrimage for
tens of thousands of shareholders
it's really an amazing thing the stadium
is filled and
the spotlights are on a small folding
table
with two 80 year olds at that table and
those two 80 year olds have more stamina
than anyone else in the room
he goes non-stop from friday to sunday
night
and and as the weekend goes on he gets
more energy
can't explain it it's got to be those
burgers
in the 2000s buffett was worth tens of
billions of dollars
money he planned on giving away to a
foundation to be run by his wife susie
but in 2004 susie died of a stroke
following cancer surgery it was
a huge shock for all of us my dad
i can't i can't explain how much he
loved her and how much he
relied on her i am going to start crying
talking about this um
it you know he'll never totally get over
it
none of us probably will but she was
really something very special
two years after his wife susie's death
buffett married ostrich menks in a
private ceremony
and he announced that he was pledging
the bulk of his fortune
not to his children but to the
foundation run by bill
and melinda gates bill gates has been
one of buffett's closest friends
since the early 1990s so it was
you know kind of phenomenal it made us
step up our ambition level uh at a lot
of things we wouldn't have
been able to do and so now every year
it's a gigantic gift that allows us to
be double what we would have been
without it
buffett's reputation was as much
celebrity as brilliant businessman
when the u s economy plunged into crisis
mode in 2008
warren buffett was again seen as a
savior to many of the financial
institutions collapsing under mountains
of debt
the dow closed monday session down more
than 500 points
warren buffett is one enormous good
housekeeping seal of approval and if
he's putting money into a situation
they're going to assume that he's
intelligent enough to be making that
investment because he thinks he's going
to generate
a satisfactory return off of it and that
will calm people's fears
when fear is at its highest among the
businesses that received lifelines from
warren buffett
were goldman sachs ge and later
bank of america but as buffett continues
into his eighties
one question persists who will succeed
this financial icon
at the head of berkshire hathaway a
successor has been identified
but that name has not yet been made
public
what he has made public are the
political and economic causes that he
feels passionate about
i think in the last couple years
he has seen some places where he thinks
if i open my mouth
it might make a difference what he's
most vocal about
is what he sees as the inequities of the
tax system
something that's come to be known as the
buffett rule there's all kinds of ultra
rich
who pay normal taxes but there are
there's a small segment but you can find
them very easily
who pay very low taxes including me
he considers himself you know lucky to
have been born in america at this time
in history
well i think he's one of the most
memorable peaceful i've ever met
he's touched a lot of lives with what
he's done
and everybody that he's dealt with has
made money doing it
and it's improved their life there are
really no people like
warren where you know we should sit back
and
and benefit from the deep thinking he's
done about
business since he was very young
i just have a great time every day i
mean i i am beginning to do exactly what
i want to do in life
it doesn't get any better than that